among the first to congratulate Donald
Trump on victory were some names you may
have heard before
Dutch right-wing populists scared
builders French fault National Party
chief marine lepen
Hungarian national conservative Prime
Minister Viktor Orban and the leading
lady of Germany's anti-immigration party
the AFD I believe that with him there is
a chance for a new beginning that is
urgently needed not only in America but
worldwide in the US Trump supporters
screamed lock her up referring to
Hillary Clinton in Germany the
Nationalists anti-islam pegida movement
shout Merkel must go on both sides of
the Atlantic supporters of populist
movements are similarly shrill and
they're convinced that the political
elite is corrupt populist parties in
Europe can now say see the establishment
and the media write that you may be in
the minority but in reality in an
election you can see that what we are
saying does indeed represent the
majority so we are the voice of the
silent majority - like the growing
confidence of the outspoken right has
got many established politicians worried
not least among them Chancellor Merkel
herself witnessing hatred and agitation
being displayed without inhibition not
only anonymously on the Internet but on
the streets demonstrations or in front
of refugee shelters we must not ignore
this and yet even if right-wing populist
think that they are on the rise a
victory like Trump's in the US would
hardly be possible in Germany with its
multi-party system the IFD comes if even
if the AFD had a very very good election
result they wouldn't take power not even
if they got 40% which is not likely that
wouldn't happen since here it's not the
party with the greatest relative
strength that rules but rather a
coalition government the needs a
majority but still the rise of the right
cannot be ignored and everyone in the
German parliament at least is well aware
of what that means